écoute d'un bon score julie tu vas tout
fait rater
enfin kouthia une heure que je suis là
sans bouger je commence à avoir des
crampes mais un bon modèle ne bouge pas
d'ailleurs tu n'en a plus pour longtemps
où j'ai presque terminé mon chef
d'oeuvre à bas j'ai hâte de voir ça ne
bouge pas alors
alors ces portraits town est presque
fini quasi mais tu es content de ton
travail plutôt rory je crois qu'en ce
tableau va faire date dans l'histoire de
la peinture
tu permets que je le regarde on écoute
un artiste n'aime pas tellement que l'on
regarde son oeuvre avant qu'elle soit
terminée
mais comme il ne me reste plus que
quelques retouches à faire
je veux bien oh merci beaucoup mon cher
net remercie alors c'est bourrin pas si
c'est très intéressant
ça semble en bas il faut sans aucun
doute faire la part de l'interprétation
de l'artiste est ce que ça me rendrait
ce que ça me ressembles part je peux
rien dire non il faut mieux que tu vois
toi même attend encore une seconde
voilà c'est moi ça oui si tu veux
regarde qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
là
mais sait-on par page ou dit n'importe
quoi tu te fiches de moi non je
comprends je lis que de soi un petit peu
surprise mais mais c'est casimir t'as vu
comme ça tu peux pas lui en vouloir
maputo - c'est pas lui qui est resté
deux heures immobile et bunge sait plus
quoi dire mais entre vous deux et dudu
comprend julie casimir en tant
qu'artiste avait le droit de te plaindre
ainsi s'il te rien si les casimir
effectivement pour ce genre de peinture
du n'aurait peut-être pas dû infliger à
ton modèle une aussi longue séance de
pose est est ce
oh voilà monsieur du snop qui arrive il
va pouvoir nous donner un avis éclairé
ça maintenant qu'ils me reconnaissent
non non c'est pas vrai ce tableau
représente non seulement ton visage mais
également ton caractère des jaunards
selon ses amis bonjour monsieur n'est ce
coup là que vois je
voilà une oeuvre extrêmement
intéressante and spa et justement nous
vous attendions pour que vous ne donniez
votre opinion sur ce tableau vous êtes
un spécialiste je crois reconnu dans le
monde entier - ferrari n'oubliez pas que
de rires je vais exposer à paris new
york londres pays que tu es nous sommes
tous passionnés par votre carrière de
peintre
mais dans l'immédiat c'est votre opinion
sur ce tableau qui nous intéresse c'est
beau hein attendaient que je regarde
alors c'est bon mais tu as raison
casimir c'est un joli portrait tu vois
on trouvait que ça ressemble à un
portrait ma chère amie n'y a aucun doute
pour un professionnel
aqua voyez vous c'est une idée très si
elles ne représentent pas à proprement
parler un visage elle en évoque
indiscutablement les proportions
oui oui mais caractère du personnage
celui dans l'ardeur du pinceau non
croyez moi mon cher ami
ce portrait lumineux excuse-moi casimir
j'ai peut-être été un peu sévère avec
toiture en juillet lui il a un vrai sens
artistique un tableau me plaît beaucoup
le savent et surtout dans la
compréhension du modèle cas 4e profane
c'est à dire personne qui ne comprend
rien à la peinture ce table ou ne
représente pas un portrait mais pour un
professionnel spécialiste
on connaît tout de suite le visage de
notre brave et mille fois que dites vous
je dis que dans ceux portant reconnaît
notre brave facteurs pas ses mots
c'est un scandale juridique du calme car
nous voyons mon cher ami je vous
comprends pas votre réaction vous avez
quelque chose à reprocher à notre brave
m ils n'ont pas du tout pas du tout mais
aussi du snob mais julie était un petit
peu surprise c'est normal alors vous
voyez dans ce portrait le visage du
fatah ne fait aucun doute ma chère amie
regardez on connaît même un certain
embonpoint jusqu'à la coiffure
autant vous dire la vérité monsieur du
slap ce portrait c'est le mien quoi
casimir mais tu portes ou ne ressemble à
rien je me voyais on en sait pas s'il
vous vous ne connaissez absolument rien
alors ça vous est très facile de dire
n'importe quoi
kazmir te prendra qu'une personne la
qualité des jamais n'importe quoi vous
vous êtes un peintre du dimanche
incapable coin mauvais mauvais à rien je
suis arrêté tous les deux mais vous
conduisez comme des gars ne faisait vous
savez tenir un pinceau de ma chère amie
tu seras peut-être reconnu par toute la
critique
eh bien nous allons voir ça vous allez
chaque affaire le porter de l'autre et
charbit tracé compris c'est compris est
compris
[Musique]
[Rires]
ma chère amie ce n'est pas possible
comment voulez vous faire une oeuvre
d'art avec un modèle que les yeux aussi
globuleux croire aux autres messieurs
ils sont peut être en gros mais ils sont
au moins vivent en regardant les ventes
j'ai l'impression de peindre un poisson
mort si je le retenais pas eh bien ne
vous retenez pas ça me donnera
l'occasion de vous peindre la figure ce
qui aura au moins l'avantagé de la
cacher cessez de vous disputer est
retourné à mon tableau c'est pas
possible une tête pareil mais c'est
incroyable incroyable non
il est il est moche il y vraiment trop
moche bonjour mademoiselle julie à vos
jeux factor vous allez bien aux
merveilles mademoiselle julie
que demander de plus je pensais en
revenant jusqu'ici que j'ai bien la
chance de vivre dans l'île aux enfants
c'est vrai tout le monde est si gentil
avec moi je n'ai que des amis 1
vous avez raison factor vous êtes un
sage
à casimir et monsieur du snop qui font
de la peinture
oui une sorte de concours voilà qui
capturent et 110 dont non ne me dîtes
surtout rien je vais essayer de devoir
de comprendre ce qu'ils sont entrain de
pain c'est une très bonne idée facteurs
on va voir si vous reconnaissez quelque
chose
or on ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai un
jugement assez juste je vous fais
confiance aux boks alors là ça ne fait
aucun pour qu'arras a voir absolument
qu'avez vous découvert je lis ils sont
en train de faire tous les deux votre
portrait
il ya vraiment comme moi qui connaissent
quelque chose en peinture ici
[Musique]